In dark, honest moments, we are liable to
recognise – with considerable agony – that
there is so much missing from our lives. We
have been unable to get quite the career we
wanted. Our partners leave us largely unfulfilled.
We have made some catastrophic mistakes that
can never be corrected. Our appearance is
shameful and in decline. And there is, correspondingly,
so much that we envy. No philosopher has ever
taken envy more seriously than Friedrich Nietzsche.
The 19th-century German philosopher described
it as the most important emotion at work in
individual and collective life. In his writings,
he referred to it with a slightly unusual
word, the French term ressentiment – which
places emphasis on the humiliation we experience
in the face of what we desire but cannot have.
In his book On The Genealogy of Morality,
published in 1887, Nietzsche presents us with
a ground-breaking diagnosis of envy. He opens
with a speculative history of how our ideas
of good and evil developed – and the crucial
role of envy therein. In ancient times, Nietzsche
argued, what counted as negative or positive
was defined in a rather direct and simple
way by the powerful. Those who held military,
financial and political authority
got to decide what sort
of actions and behaviours would be thought
admirable. Because of the aristocrats’ attachments
and tastes, ‘good’ came to be synonymous
with aristocratic values like winning, making
money, being confidently sexual, knowing a
lot and securing fame. Assured of their own
virtue, the powerful in ancient times slept
soundly. But the aristocracy’s reign did
not go on unchallenged. There were too many
weak, powerless and downtrodden people at
large, a mass of men and women whom Nietzsche
alternately and with a dark playfulness – deliberately
designed to appall sensitivities – called
‘the slaves’, ‘the plebeians’ or ‘the
herd’. These people increasingly wanted
to avenge themselves against the powerful.
At the same time, they lacked any practical
means of doing so, having no money or political
leverage. Then they hit on an idea of genius:
They would
fight back against the rich and the strong
with the weapon of guilt. They couldn’t
attack the powerful physically, but they could
leave them unable to sleep well at night.
They would ruin them
via their consciences. A central weapon in
this revenge attack was – for Nietzsche
– the ideology we know today as Christianity.
Christianity was for the philosopher a brilliant,
devilish instrument of revenge dreamt up by
the weak to make the strong feel guilty for
their advantages. It was Christianity’s
strategy to relabel as bad everything once
associated with aristocratic values – and
to anoint with the term good everything with
which the ‘herd’ was identified. So, in
the new Christian moral scheme, having no
money was relabelled ‘noble poverty’,
having no education was praised as ‘sincerity’,
lacking sex was hailed as ‘chastity’ – and,
as Nietzsche put it, ‘not-being-able-to-take-revenge’
turned into ‘forgiveness.’ Envious for
what they couldn’t have, Christians made
the powerful feel untenably guilty – and
insisted that the kingdom of God belonged
to the weak, the meek, the chaste, the poor
and the persecuted.
Nietzsche
almost admired the audacity of this move but
at the same time held it to be responsible
for an appalling bad faith and the degradation
of European civilisation. In a cantankerous
tone, he wrote that: The man of ressentiment
is neither upright nor naïve, nor honest
and straight with himself. His soul squints;
his mind loves dark corners, secret paths
and back-doors. For Nietzsche, the psychological
health of a person or society depends on being
able to resist denigrating what one wants
but can’t have. It involves resisting the
urge to deny the gaps in one’s life for
the sake of inner convenience. It is, for
Nietzsche, always better to say what one wishes
to be and have rather than to twist one’s
entire personality to avoid discomfort. We
must, for the philosopher, be strong enough
to face, and stay honest about, our own misfortunes.
Though Nietzsche spent a lot of time studying
Christianity, he understood that the desire
to redraw values on the basis of repressed
envy was a manoeuvre that could appear under
many guises. His attacks may seem harsh and
potentially even an absurd defence of boorish
upper class set of values. But it’s important to
remember that Nietzsche himself was no aristocrat:
he lacked money, sex, an audience, friends
– but he was committed to honesty with himself
and so didn’t shirk away from admitting
that, in certain moods, he would dearly have
wished to be more heroic, fulfilled and brave,
yet lacked the talent to be so. Nietzsche’s
message is that one of the most mature acts
we are capable of is to admit to the strength
of our envy – and the scale of our regret
– without falling prey to defensive philosophies
of denial, in all their many and ingenious
disguises. Our Western Philosophy cards, features
20 of the best ideas from Eastern philosophy.  Click on the link on screen now to  find out more.